hisses hit the like button if you like
the dog I'm gonna stop spending time
with Deena this cost $62
- [ __ ] Anthony stop smoking effect what
our recommendation it's time for another
male time
[Music]
hello everybody hope you're having an
amazing weekend we've got a whole bunch
of packages we've done this in a while
bunch of toxins entertain in that I'm
going to open up and you want to send me
anything to be featured on a future mail
time the address students Montaigne
studio is in the link below and live a
little prescription below the
description below so go check that out
send you some stuff and the ability
featured I'm feeling too loud folks
today the guys want me to a lot of you
this is the first one to be chained team
oh by the way that's my four month old
House of Blues nation we need a chemo
close up book there is what do you think
okay pizzas hit the like button if you
like the dog C Mon look look at the
camera look smile at the camera
Nina has to go that Wow Yuma look at
that look at me now ro
okay stop the shark missed a meal time
okay
melt our our our first one envelope Oh
Alexa T check oh yeah
open hope your wife how do i it's tight
as as soon as you get it and let me know
how how this kinky listen oh wow what is
it micro dermabrasion tape
microdermabrasion paste for Nina yeah
left it on the front yeah okay you know
what okay just stop skin - Lisa come
here a sec hi okay next airmails is a
definite book from the UK but I have so
many books it's good though
the successful mistake by Matthew Turner
Thank You Matthew
looking for learning what domestic the
successful mistake is I like to find to
look look at how the olds are underlined
oh yes
although I use the Sun doesn't say
Amazon Fulfillment Center okay
definitely plus oh boy do we have
Oh
Scott Carney what doesn't kill us
this is based off the bottom hot I'm
glad you came back and went off not that
long ago
this is went off near Times bestseller I
like it got Carney looking for polar
bonds in pop thank you I'm looking
forward to this one and Thank You
economy Gary Vaynerchuk thank you kindly
next take the Random House is another
book from Keith Kennedy hey and the book
the difference when good enough isn't
enough the simple characteristic two
separate good companies and great
companies okay Nina boom Peng Random
House another look
I'm going to stop spending time with
Dina so it can't be devoting all of
these like it was all the paper Random
House Committee put the happiness
equation offices Neil Neil country chest
happiness equation what nothing folks do
anything people have everything in a top
10 on meal we came into the studio I
mentioned that I had a little library at
TDS I'm a dance studio he said he wanted
to donate some of the books to the dance
to do not let the spacing of the front
what do you mean like it's easy to read
well Neil Neil sold over a million book
who knows a little bit of a book book
reading nice thank you
the next one is from Rachel and support
but this real artist don't start just
going Bible studies subscribing in a new
creative age a legend is born old
advanced reader copy the advance copy
but immediately
publishing date directory of June Oh
June 2017 all right thank you your next
one is time tchau tchau
humming sixteen is happening and sleep
Charles eggs Lee it's not a book hard
work
yeah Joey it feels like it's clothing
clothing yes something out of our right
good
I don't want to be mine LT 30 ha it's a
t-shirt hold onto the letter organism
t-shirt with the letter the anomaly
mission statement something a DB
somewhat a standard normal or expected
my name is Prince Charles Anjali and
then I am the creator of the anomaly
clothing I want to make this branch as I
want to inspire me people think about
the magic of the world has to offer
the of the radical abnormalities of
positivity we see every so often which
is designed to inspire time simply a
walk t-shirts change the world for the
good followed by like eight exclamation
points all right Prince Charles is Lee
the vision where dreams begin there we
go this cost sixty two dollars to ship
from the US sixty two dollars
it says one letter of intro one dollar
value with $60 shipping well I'm curious
look at this come on this is a
preventable eventually just like the
shortest letter my name is Kamal and I
have invented a machine to manufacturing
pellets that I played under the skin to
treat medical conditions patents been
filed
I'm trying to convince the market I will
discuss my interaction with you and how
we have to vote tomorrow I mean you got
on the show but I'm not really into
telus just email me but it's not really
up my alley if I can help you something
a licking ohm or let me know write to me
but I'm going to sit by my
investment point of view Salvador where
three days under the letter e whoa look
at this thing holy cow he or she
hammered him Salvador's a guy
I'm Roseburg Oregon look at you know
yeah look at this
not not typing intimate contain written
this is page for the top look at that
can we see an end of the yellow one -
Wow
new song I I will not live my life
defeated take one no no no I will not
let my light repeated no no no sit so
this is his script for believe believe
believe hath based on sing this song
making a video and send it to me
Salvador I want to see it hi dear Ivan
my name is Salvador please excuse my bad
writing I want to let you know how much
I enjoy YouTube enjoy all tasks and your
book your book your one word thank you
guys inspire me to believe I've been
reading books and watching videos and
Tony Robbins Jack Canfield and on and
you are among the best motivational
speakers Thank You Salvador I would love
that you can do attending will success
on Neil Nitin le gallant I know that is
so we haven't we have a link underneath
this video check the description of the
link where you can vote we're using that
video for people to vote on who they won
the next top ten cold well thank you for
the effort I mean I'm going to read this
on camera I appreciate the love Salvador
this feels like a lot ELISA Adler over a
holiday right holidays new book you
didn't tell me
Brian writing let you know dude I'm
going to open this sooner unfriended
proofs illumines distribution perennial
cell is the art of making any marketing
work that lasts I like it I like it Ryan
I'm gonna check it out envelope from
lawyers oh you're like a book either
book or a boxes you are being sued for
being amazing another book daring
Colucci everything I've never learned in
school go how to be successful by daring
solution all right
by airmail envelope problem today
although Jeremy America's H in Chicago
he had the greeting card business of
what he does and he made a video not too
long ago about why we spend down patient
cards of people who I didn't happen to
place somebody except me
and they wrote this nice message inside
I just want to thank you for inspiring
me to suberino you can check out hey I'm
will enjoy your book - I love that visit
a you posted a story Instagram that
resonate with me and gave you a real
boost thank you for everything you do to
support entrepreneurs very inspiring I
hope that you are keeping well and you
enjoyed the boogie candy bar incident
isn't mine he was the eighth one right
we need one do you see the right I still
have them so Michelle hope to see you
gain another place on my jury Jeremy
Jeremy you rock man thank you for this
last but not least when we got not some
Google look laptop our picture what is
Google's and I mean it's a nice look it
out yet but gets packaging ok you go
open it up let's meet face to face
scheduled meeting was Harold
the Director of Digital Strategy and
we'll send you a Chromebook for a video
call if you want to meet with me and
Ivania laptop and they gave me a laptop
case but I'd like you to be a part of
the digital strategy program we've
developer group I've selected two
successful businesses all right what do
you think should I do it should I need
Harrow
oh man so on this thing is that's next
time you can get
I know whoo all right that is it thank
you guys for the Nina facial
microdermabrasion the microdermabrasion
paint paste t-shirt all of us and Harold
from Google who wants the meat and give
me a Chromebook I appreciate the lab
hope you had an amazing weekend again if
you want to send me stuff to the next
edition of mealtime the adverts in
Toronto that salsa is in the description
looking forward to seeing what you guys
have get some free promotion on my
channel and hopefully if I use your
thing I'm going to promote it as well
because I'd like to talk about the stuff
I use let's take them get a big weekend
when you want to say thank you pretty
their stuff yes you know what's up come
on guys sending us up again Nina but
Nina likes time we believe in you we
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one more in much
left we will see hey you gotta record a
team I want to say goodbye goodbye
goodbye believe nation we'll see you
soon